guten abend frau rutschte er darf der
arbeitgeber das hat mich quasi fast
zwingen mich impfen zu lassen
an meiner seite ein ganz klares nein
also natürlich wird das unter uns
juristen gerade diskutiert also viele
arbeitsrechtler sagen es gibt nur eine
treuepflicht auch von seiten der
arbeitnehmer also quasi sich pandemie
konform zu verhalten
aber das ist noch die absolute
minderheit also da muss man wirklich
ganz klar sagen die allermeisten
arbeitsrechtler sagen da genauso wie ich
das ist ein eingriff in die körperliche
unversehrtheit also ein ganz ganz
starker eingriff in die rechte der
arbeitnehmer und das kann ich eben plant
direktionsrecht so heißt das ganze als
arbeitgeber nicht durchsetzen
gleichzeitig tragen aber eher
mitarbeiter ja in arztpraxen oder in
pflege stationen in krankenhäusern eine
besondere verantwortung also die sorge
dieses arztes ist ja durchaus
nachvollziehbar gibt es da gewisse
sonder regelungen gibt es schon
natürlich überhaupt wenn man zu einer
treuepflicht kommt also wenn man sagt
jemand muss sich impfen lassen dann
allenfalls in diesen berufen
und ja vielleicht als beispiel es gibt
auch schon so eine gesetzliche regelung
nämlich zu machen da es ist tatsächlich
so dass vorgesehen ist der wert zum
beispiel in einer arztpraxis arbeitet
oder auch in einer kita dass der sich
eben ins muss einfach aufgrund der
vielen menschlichen kontakte der
ansteckungsgefahr
und da es ist tatsächlich so dass das
gesundheitsamt dann wenn es eben keine
impfung gibt auch ein tätigkeitsverbot
aussprechen kann also faktisch da die
kündigung dann droht weil man ja
praktisch so nicht arbeiten kann
ohne eine entsprechende regelung für
corona sehe ich das nicht also weder die
freistellung noch gar die freistellung
ohne entgelt auch als arbeitnehmer hat
man nämlich ein recht auf arbeit also
sprich selbst das kann nämlich alleine
durchsetzen und schon mal gar nicht
ohne das geld gezahlt wird darf denn der
chef der arbeitgeber einen test
verlangen nach dem ziel ist es immer die
gleiche abwägung wie groß ist sozusagen
der eingriff in die rechte der
arbeitnehmer und wie groß ist das
interesse des chefs und da würde ich
jetzt schon eher sagen
natürlich kann man das auch diskutieren
natürlich werden das wahrscheinlich auch
gerichte entscheiden
aber hier ist es schon eher so dass ich
sage der eingriff in die rechte des
arbeitnehmers ist deutlich geringer
und das interesse des arbeitgebers kann
ich nachvollziehen gerade in solchen
bereichen wie eben arzt vielleicht sogar
einrichtung wir sehen das auch zu zweit
bei alters meinen also da würde ich eher
sagen ja aber auch das kann man
natürlich gerichtlich überprüfen lassen
wie ist es denn bei
vorstellungsgesprächen darf ich dort
danach gefragt werden ob ich geimpft
werde und darf sich danach dann auch die
entscheidung richten aber ich
eingestellt werde oder nicht
ja alles rechtliches neuland aber auch
da um eine klare einschätzung ja das
darf ich als arbeitgeber fragen in
meinen augen besteht dann tatsächlich
ein berechtigtes interesse ein
nachvollziehbares interesse weil
natürlich auch die fürsorgepflichten die
der arbeitgeber hat entsprechend
vielleicht anders sind wenn man wird
jemand hat der geimpft ist dann muss man
vielleicht im betrieb weniger maßnahmen
zum schutz der eigenen mitarbeiter der
kollegen vielleicht auch der patienten
ergreifen als wenn eben jemand nicht
geimpft ist oder eben anders rum also
spricht da würde ich sagen die frage ist
zulässig und entsprechend müsste ich sie
als arbeitnehmer auch wahrheitsgemäß
beantworten also nachfrage nach der
impfung ist erlaubt sie verpflichten als
arbeitgeber
das ist nicht erlaubt das sagt nicole
mutschke anwältin vielen herzlichen dank
für das gespräch
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren